servants why are we seeing this
dislocation with natural gas prices in
the Northeast so within the Northeast
let's talk about the supply and demand
balance within the Northeast the supply
has been so prolific you have this
structural the secular shift in how
prolific these Appalachian wells are so
take the Marcellus the Marcels for
example 10 years ago very limited output
today the Marcellus is roughly 16.5 BCF
a day that's billion cubic feet per day
on a national run rate of roughly 70
some-odd billion cubic feet per day on
dry gas layer on top of that the utica
most recent developments 2.5 bcf a day
so within the Appalachian Basin you have
roughly 19 bcf of capacity that not long
ago you did not have basically the
Northeast nor nat gas is like a
microcosm for the issue that kind of
plagues the oil market in the country as
a whole you have a lot of supply and you
know how the transportation that meets
up the only difference is this capacity
is coming from one location one general
area not long ago the Northeast was a
big importer of gas during the heating
and cooling season this has now been
reversed as the Northeast has become
more self-sufficient in providing its
own volume its own output to meet those
seasonal heating and cooling needs so as
we see the infrastructure issues build
and you're not going to be able to get
the gas out to the customers who may
need it the most on the east coast is at
gasco elsewhere and displace gas say in
the south or the Midwest so when you
think about the capacity additions from
2015 2016 and 2017 in 2015 and in 2016
you're likely have somewhere around six
to seven bcf of additional capacity the
biggest capacity likely comes online in
2017 we're tracking something worth of
17 BCF
of transportation capacity coming on
where this capacity likely ends up a big
chunk of that capacity will likely end
up in the Gulf Coast and out into the
Midwest roughly six bcf now the Gulf
Coast capacity is interesting because
that allows for LNG exports and
providing an additional demand outlet
for that capacity